The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
So we've come to a topic that
I think feels to us like
intuitively almost the core of
psychology might be about is
personality.
Why are some things easy
for us and hard for us?
Why do we like some things
or something else?
Why do people around us behave
kindly or rudely, supportively
or loyally or whatever?
What can we understand about
personality scientifically?
So how do psychologists try
to study it in a somewhat
systematic fashion?
Some key concepts that we're
finding are traits, states,
and context.
Traits--
I'll come to these.
And then finally some brain
correlates for personality.
So I love this quote, because
I think it's about
individuality, which says, every
person is in certain
respects like all
other people--
and we think that's true.
There's something deeply similar
among all humans, also
about psychology, also
about our brains.
Like some other people, that
is, there's dimensions of
individuality, or like some
other people, like if we're a
male or female, if we're this
age or that age, this culture
or that culture, like math or
don't like math, like vanilla
ice cream or don't
like ice cream.
And then finally, we come down
to the unique set of things
that make you you.
And that's very hard to study,
the unique things
that make you you.
But the second level, dimensions
of individuality,
we can study in personality.
It's obviously a big one
that we feel in our own
lives and around us.
So this is the old original
"Star Trek." Like many
programs, or in TV series, it
plays out really in part--
they go from galaxy to galaxy
and struggle with various
opponents, civilizations.
But it almost always
comes down to a
personality thing, right?
The Captain Kirk who wants to
be aggressive and charge in
there and do something very
emotional, Spock who's the
pure rational machine, and McCoy
who represents a sort of
humane touch, as opposed to
the rational thought.
And somewhere in between is the
man who has to pick the
action to command
the ship, right?
So every show plays out
with him asking him
to be human, right?
And him asking him to be
rational, and him killing
somebody who's trouble making.
OK.
So what do we mean
by personality?
A set of behavioral, emotional,
and cognitive
tendencies that people
display over time.
When we talk about personality,
we really mean
something that we think is
consistent in ourselves or in
other people.
It's that somebody is
shy, somebody's
helpful, somebody's rude.
And across situations, not just
one place, one time, but
pretty regularly.
And that varies across people.
That distinguishes them
from one to another.
Something that's kind of--
there's some similarities,
but people vary in this.
And so when people think about
this, they think in three
categories as they
conceptualize it.
One is traits.
By trait we mean something
that's in you that's constant
across situations and times.
But we also think of
it as a continuum.
So for example, we talk about
introversion/extroversion or
outgoingness and shyness.
It's not that everybody's
one or the other.
Along that path from being
extremely shy to extremely
outgoing, many of us are
somewhere in between.
And then we can talk about
states, how we are
temporarily.
How do we feel, excited, afraid,
that kind of stuff.
And then situations we're in,
because they're specific at
times and places, and
that influences us.
We're fearful, we're happy,
we're looking forward to
something, we're not looking
forward to something.
So these are different pieces
that might end up in how we
feel inside and how we
act on the world.
So here's a very funny thing,
because it's a very different
line of research than
practically anything else
that's out there.
Very active, because we're so
curious about personality.
Here's how people have basically
approached it.
Not everybody, but the main line
scientific perspective.
They looked in the dictionary,
originally in the 1930s, for
this line of work, and they
said, let's look at all the
adjectives in the dictionary
that we think might describe
personality in some sense.
They found nearly 18,000 words
in the dictionaries that
seemed to be adjectives for
describing people, and
something that might be
about personality.
Whether you're affable, or
amiable, congenial, convivial,
cordial, friendly, genial,
sociable, welcoming.
These are all synonyms, right?
They all mean roughly the
same thing, we think.
But they found 18,000 terms
there because we think a lot
about other people, and talk a
lot about other people, and
other people are interesting
to us.
And as I said, we're not going
to study 18,000 dimensions of
personality, especially
when lots of them
overlap like this.
So what we're going to do is
see, are there some underlying
traits, a manageable set of
personality traits or
dimensions, that many of these
18,000 adjectives sort
of boil down to.
So a manageable set of
personality dimensions.
So how do people measure
personality in some way?
And for those of us who like
to measure things by
behavior-- you do a test, or
you push a button, or we
measure your brain--
personality research is always
funny, because the bulk of it
is people's self report
about themselves.
And about the last thing most
of us in psychology trust is
people's reports about
themselves.
And what we think is--
for many reasons that we can
talk about a little bit--
what we think is that people,
when they fill out a piece of
paper describing themselves,
they start to have all kinds
of thoughts like, OK, I'm
outgoing, but compared to who?
Do I want to fill this out like
I really like to think
about myself, or how I think I
really am, or am I sometimes
this way and sometimes
that way, which
is the right answer.
OK?
So all these things bother us
as researchers, but we don't
have a more direct path
towards personality.
So we can interview people
about their personality.
We can observe--
I'll talk about some studies
that involve observation.
But by far the dominant mode
of collecting somewhat
quantitative data about
personality are questionnaires
of the kind you just got
handed out to you.
Thank you, Tyler.
And the most famous one of all,
which you have in your
hands, is the so-called big five
personality dimensions.
There's many other aspects of
personality-- we'll talk about
that-- but this is the
most famous one.
And it was derived in some
sense objectively and
empirically from factor
analysis like this.
What they said is we have this
huge number of terms, but many
of them are either very similar
to one another, or
what we might call
anti-correlative, they're sort
of opposites.
So for example, if a person is
rude, are we also likely to
think of them as kind?
Now you could have--
there's many movies of the rude
senior citizen who turns
out to have a heart of gold
underneath, right?
But in general, if you say this
person's rude, usually
they'll go, and they're
so kind, right?
We think of them as sort of
opposites in personality.
If somebody's dependable
or carefree.
Now, maybe you know somebody
who's both dependable and
carefree, but we tend to think
carefree people are not so
dependable.
They can be delightful
dependable people.
But now, rude-- you can be
dependable and rude or
dependable and polite, right?
OK, so get a feeling of that.
So they have people fill out
tons of pieces of paper saying
how do they feel these factors
describe them.
And they start out with this
huge universe of terms, and
then they try to boil it down,
and boil it down, and boil it
down, by looking at--
Oh, this doesn't show up
very well, does it?
Oh, well.
Correlations--
you have the notes.
So you can guess without being
able to see, you can guess--
let's pick two things.
If I pick the adjectives
carefree and dependable, kind
of go together or
not go together?
Doesn't tend to go together in
people describing themselves.
How about hard working
and dependable?
Kind of goes together.
So they said, we can take a lot
of these adjectives and
say piles of them go in one
area, well, we'll just pick a
few words to describe
that dimension.
Piles of them go in
another area.
And they boil it down basically
by factor analysis,
and they end up with five
big factors in this
most widely used one.
So here's two of them.
And here comes a big thing.
They have the factor which is
basically just mathematically
a set of adjectives that travel
together, that are
highly correlated when people
describe themselves.
And they're somewhat
anti-correlated or
uncorrelated with the
other dimensions.
That's purely empirical.
Now, though, they have the set
of adjectives, like carefree
or dependable, not hard-working
or hard-working.
Now they have to say, what's the
label I'm going to put on
that dimension of human
personality?
There's no science for that.
That's judgment.
But five of them get fixed.
And once these got fixed,
they've become the terminology
of the field.
So they said, we're going to
call one conscientiousness.
Those are people who say they're
not carefree, they are
dependable, and they
are hard-working.
Does that make sense?
Or somebody's agreeable--
that's one of the other big
five, separate five.
If somebody says, I'm pretty
compliant, I'm pretty kind,
and I'm seldom rude.
So I'm going to give you
a minute to try this.
You can fill it out fully.
So your piece of paper
that you have is a
version of this test.
It's the real thing.
One side tells you
how to score it.
Don't look at that, the other
side at the bottom.
Just try a few items for fun
if you feel like it.
And you can fill it out later
and score yourself or print it
out from the notes and
score your friends.
Use it responsibly,
the knowledge.
And you can just have an
intuition of what does it
mean, because almost all
personality research, almost
all of it does exactly what
you're doing now, which is
gives you a piece of paper, and
have you describe yourself
to yourself.
I'll give you a minute just
to get a feeling for it.
I think it's kind of fun.
And the feeling you
get, like--
so people worry about stuff,
like who are you comparing
yourself to?
If you're outgoing,
compared to who?
Compared to Robin
Williams, OK?
Maybe not so much.
Compared to your roommate?
Maybe yes.
So all these questions, like
where do you get these number
from, how do you come to these
answers, and so on.
People worry about polishing
your image.
Oh yes, I'm always polite.
I'm nearly perfect when I'm
asked to describe myself, OK?
So to the extent that
people did that, it
wouldn't work, right?
Because everybody would look
perfect all the time.
So these big five are openness,
conscientiousness,
extroversion, agreeableness,
and neuroticism.
And for memorizing for tests,
OCEAN is the acronym.
These were the ones that have
come out as five separable
dimensions that seem to cover
a tremendous amount of
individual descriptions of human
personality, and are
widely used in research.
So here's your big
five inventory.
Here's--
on the backside, how to score
it, if you feel like figuring
out what this test would
say about yourself, OK?
You could be honest with your
scoring, because we're not
going to collect it, it's just
you describing you to
yourself, if you're curious.
And now I'm going to go on.
And you're more than welcome
to finish it
whenever you want.
It's yours to keep.
And here's how we would score
it, or you would score it.
It tells you on the
bottom what to do.
For conscientiousness--
and we'll come back
to this, it's a
really interesting measure.
If you rate yourself as somebody
who does a thorough
job, is a reliable worker,
perseveres until the task is
finished, does things
efficiently, and makes plans
and follows through with them.
The higher you rate yourself on
those-- this makes sense--
you're more conscientious,
right?
The less you say, that you're
somewhat careless, you tend to
be disorganized, you tend to
be lazy, and you're easily
distracted, well, those
are negative
things for that dimension.
Does that make sense?
So you have to watch when you
score it which are the
positive and which are the
negative as you score them,
would you get a plus
or a minus.
And they try to make it either
way, so that if you constantly
say yes, you ought not to score
anything that makes
sense, even to yourself.
Anyway, so here's the big
questions, right?
All this sort of research
behind or this factor
analysis, you'd want
to know two things.
Are they stable?
Do they really describe
a person across
situations and time?
That's what we mean
by personality.
And secondly, do they predict
behaviors and life outcomes?
Is there something about them
that goes with things that we
care about, variably
across people?
So where people have looked at
this over some number of
years, it correlates 0.5
to 0.7 across 30
or 40 years of life.
Height and sex, to think about
it, correlates 0.4.
Again, height and sex is kind of
an-- people will pick that
to think about.
On average, men tend to be
taller than women, but lots of
women are taller than lots
of individual men, OK?
So it's a stronger relationship
across time.
It's more stable than
what you'd predict
by height and sex.
And here's something
really interesting.
They tested people across
seven years-- within
childhood, within young
adulthood, within the 30s, and
in the 50 to 70 age range.
And here's something
kind of striking.
If you test people twice across
seven years, starting
from infancy as best you can--
or questions about them
because they can't
fill out forms--
to adulthood, the striking thing
is that the older you
get, the more consistent
you become across
a seven year period.
The older you get, the more
consistent you become.
So how might you
interpret that?
There's a couple different
ways you
could think about that.
The older you become, the more
consistent you become in
describing your personality--
let's pretend your descriptions
are accurate--
the more consistent your
personality is.
Did you expect that?
Is that what you expect?
Something opposite?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They get older, they
kind of develop habits and get
set in their ways.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So there's two ways to describe
getting older.
Like me, I get set in my ways.
Right?
That's OK.
Or I'll say it the other way,
we discover the ways that we
really like.
OK?
My friend Robert Sapolsky at
Stanford, who writes fantastic
books and who's a fantastic
lecturer, had an essay where
he said he noticed in his late
40s or 50s, that the people in
his working lab that they were
playing irritating music.
It was just bothering him when
they were playing the music.
And it was music that people of
your generation listen to.
He said, why is it irritating?
Because when he played his--
when he played The Beatles or
whatever, they were irritating
to his parents, OK.
So what's going on?
And he said, oh.
And so he did a little informal
study, he talked to
people of different ages and
people in restaurants, they
said, at what age do people seem
to stop wanting to do new
things, and get stuck in their
ways, or find what they like
and stick with it?
And there's no one answer.
But he found a tremendous number
of people, by about 30
to 35, that's their music, they
like sushi or they don't
like sushi.
They have their set of stuff
that they have going for them
or they don't like.
And so you could say they
get stuck in their ways.
You could say they discover
what they like
and stick with it.
And here's an age more of
exploration and variability.
Who knows?
But it's kind of interesting,
the older you get, the more
consistent you get.
Is this flexibility?
Is this chaos?
You could look at
it either way.
There's no real answer.
People have looked at these
scores and asked whether
things like--
do they vary with
age and gender?
So for example, these broken
lines are neuroticism, which
is a funny label.
It really means--
neuroticism is the bad side
of it, stability is the
good side of it.
You could also say too stable
could be boring and inert.
You could relabel these
things pretty much.
But on average, women's scores
are a little bit less stable
than men, a little bit more
outgoing, a little bit.
By age, you get a few trends.
This will not surprise
you, actually.
So for neuroticism--
again, stability--
that neuroticism decreases
with age.
People get more stable and they
get more conscientious as
they get older.
You kind of expect that.
People get more used to their
habits and more stuck in their
ways, that we would
call stability.
So, let's ask for people who
score high or low on these
measures, what do
they go with?
So for these five fundamental
personality measures.
So people who score highly on
the neuroticism scale-- again,
these labels are tricky--
but it means ranging from very
stable and emotional sense to
very labile--
they pay more attention to
threat in the environment,
more stressed when given a
surprise math test, have a
higher divorce rate,
more susceptible to
depression and anxiety.
At the very, very, very highest
scores of neuroticism,
it's a big risk for depression
and anxiety.
And one of the deep questions
always is, to what extent are
what we call psychiatric labels
extremes of personality
or something beyond
personality?
This is a much deeper issue
than you'd think.
We'll come back to
it in psychiatry.
Because some people say there's
no such thing, for
example, as social
anxiety disorder.
It's a recent invention
for what people
used to call shyness.
I don't think that's
right, mostly.
But this debate goes on, because
there's not a sharp
boundary between being a little
shy and so shy that you
don't leave your house
to meet people.
That's kind of an extreme.
But most people--
it's not one person is here and
the next person's here,
there's people all along
the continuum.
Where you draw the line is
a challenging issue.
Highly extroverted people versus
highly introverted,
that sort of shyness
and outgoingness.
This will be a big surprise.
Highly extroverted people-- by
these personality measures--
attend more parties, they're
more popular, they're
identified as leaders in
college, they live with and
work with more people, they're
less disturbed by sudden loud
sounds or intense stimuli.
You can do experiments in a
laboratory and get these
differences.
None of these are sort
of surprising.
They're just telling you there's
something correct
about these personality
measures.
Highly agreeable people are more
willing to lend money,
have higher high school
grades, and have
fewer arrests as adults.
But the cool thing is not--
I mean, you're not surprised.
But the fact that they fill out
a questionnaire sitting at
a desk like you do, predicts to
some decent extent over the
population whether they'll
go to jail or not.
That's kind of interesting.
More openness to experience.
You're more likely to major
in the humanities--
not us--
change careers in midlife,
perform better in job training
programs, and play a
musical instrument.
But these are massive
statistical things.
Because kind of conversely--
well, you know there's very
interesting relations between
musicality and sort of math
and science backgrounds.
So that seems to go
against this.
So these are big averages.
Maybe, I think, in some ways the
most interesting one, for
practical reasons, has turned
out to be conscientiousness,
and that's like doing what
you're supposed to do.
More sexually faithful to
spouses, higher job ratings,
smoke less, drink less, drive
more safely, live longer, less
risk for Alzheimer's Disease--
spectacularly less risk.
OK?
And also play a musical
instrument?
So the Alzheimer's Disease is
kind of interesting, because
what we think is happening--
and we don't really know--
is this.
So you may know there's
basically one gene, now, more
recently, a couple other
genes, identified as
significant risk genes
for Alzheimer's.
But the one powerful
well-identified one is the
so-called APOE gene.
And that is a significant
risk gene.
If you're homologous for that,
you have a higher risk for
Alzheimer's.
But that best-known,
best-characterized gene is a
far smaller risk factor,
mathematically, than being low
conscientiousness.
And we don't know what that
really means, right?
What's your guess?
And nobody knows.
This is just an empirical
finding, and it's been
replicated a number of times.
What's your guess?
So conscientious people do
what they're supposed to.
All the things that you're
supposed to, in the morning,
get up and do, they do
them pretty well.
Right?
Make your bed, do your laundry
regularly, brush your teeth
regularly, have your medical
appointments regularly, eat
well, exercise, all the things
that everybody tells you is
good for you, conscientious
people are more
likely to do it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's sort
of an analogy.
The thing is that someone who
continuously uses them more--
more of the pipeline,
basically.
Keep water going through them,
makes it less likely that it
will clog the pipes--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
something like that.
The pipeline analogy.
If you keep flushing it
regularly, instead of clogging
it up with bad things that are
bad for you or whatever.
In the end, there has to be
a biological mechanism.
In the end, there has to be.
But maybe it's a lifetime
of doing healthy things.
And they add up and up, day in,
day out, month in, month
out, year in, year out.
That they somehow, in some
way, either fend off
Alzheimer's disease or diminish
its expression for
much longer.
Does that sound OK?
But it's a very compelling
finding.
All right.
So then there's always a
fun question up for our
personality, and there
will be one big
surprise here, I think.
I'll tell you this
is our surprise.
[INAUDIBLE] was reminding
me that--
there's a parents visiting
weekend, which
is not today, right?
But a few years ago, I gave this
lecture on that, and I
came to a conclusion that
parents will find impossible,
untrue, and very disturbing.
Get ready.
Here we go.
Again, we're always curious,
our personalities--
whether we're outgoing
or not, agreeable or
not, open or not--
how much of that is in our genes
at birth, how much is
that in our environment in terms
of parental influence,
and sibling influence, and
school, and so on.
So the usual way to this, until
we know the true biology
of this, are estimates from
twin studies and children
reared apart and reared
separately.
So let me start with
the twin studies.
So these are identical twins in
green versus dizygotic or
fraternal twins, shared
environment, some shared genes.
The difference about this is
thought to be an estimate of
pure genetic heritability.
And say you get a pretty
good one--
extroversion and openness
the most, maybe--
but definitely a genetic
contribution to personality.
That's the evidence
from twin studies.
And it's even impressive if
you do not self report
questionnaires, but behaviors
that people describe,
activities they do.
Time spent watching television,
number of
childhood accidents, tendency
for marriage and divorce,
religious attitudes, your
balance between work and
leisure, do you want to be at
work all the time or leisure,
or what the balance
ought to be.
0.5, that's about half
heritable, estimated.
Happiness--
we'll come back to happiness
ratings.
The way people rate happiness,
it turns out, is if you do a
one to seven scale,
that's the field.
OK?
Seven means happy all
the time, one means
miserable all the time.
That's the way happiness
research is done.
In the last lecture, we'll talk
about what people think
people need to do to be happy.
But one thing we know is that
people tend to have happiness
set-points--
you may know this amongst your
friends or yourselves--
that is, on average, a person
will be very happy, or
moderately happy, or pretty
grumbly most of the time.
OK?
Something happens in their lives
that's really good or
bad, they'll move a little bit,
but they'll slide right
back to it.
There's nothing better or worse
about one or the other,
but it's just people tend
to be pretty set.
And the estimates from twin
studies are about half of your
chronic sense of happiness, day
in and day out, it comes
from genes, is the estimate.
So that's a big piece.
But here's the kind
of stunning thing.
And in the next couple
slides I tell you.
Let me tell you the bottom
line, let me
tell you the evidence.
The empirical evidence could
support a position that
parents and family environments
have zero
influence on your personality.
Then the question is, what is
the environmental influence?
Because we know it's
not all genetic.
But wherever it's been looked at
carefully, parents and home
environments appear to have, as
far as they can see, nearly
zero influence on your
personality.
Now this is the thing that
drives parents crazy.
Because as a parent, I can
tell you, from the moment
they're born, or even months
before children are born, to
the moment you're no longer
around to take care of your
children, you want them to
develop the right kind of--
be a happy person,
a good person.
Hopefully something about
conscientiousness, do well in
life, right?
And you're doing every little
thing to encourage that.
The comments you make, the
schools you send them to, the
activities you encourage them to
do, you want them to have a
personality that will be happy
for them and good for them and
thriving, right?
So to be told that whatever you
do doesn't matter is kind
of a big shock.
And we don't really know
the depth of this.
And it sounds like
it's ridiculous.
But I can tell you the empirical
evidence kind of
supports it.
So for example, for the twin
studies, it makes no
difference at all for
personality dimensions whether
twins are raised together
or raised apart.
So they're in different families
or the same family--
doesn't make a difference.
All the heritable estimates
remain exactly the same.
So where are the environmental
factors coming from?
We believe there's environmental
factors, but we
can't spot them.
And what's fascinating about
these things is that we as
human beings-- and this is
just an example now--
always want to understand who we
are as some sort of willful
response to our environment.
So here are two identical
twins reared apart.
And they're both super neat.
OK?
And neither one of them tells
you, well, it's in my genes,
what else was I going to do?
None of us mostly think that.
Outside of some dire
circumstances or diseases, we
mostly think, it's my choice
this morning whether I'm going
to make my bed or not.
It's my choice if I do laundry
this year or not.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could that other 50%
come from things part of the
environment like
diet or health?
PROFESSOR: Could the other 50%
come from things like diet or
other things in the
environment?
It could.
But even that tends to
go by families some.
Some families just say, here's
a few years worth of potato
chips, good luck.
Another family's going, oh my
gosh, you didn't eat carrots
all month long.
Even that tends to be,
on average, someone
environmental, right?
Both by economic opportunity,
part of the world you're in,
parental attitudes, right?
I agree with you.
It's got to be something.
And maybe we just don't have
the whole story right.
But here's two twins telling
you why each of
them is very neat.
OK?
The first one is, my mother.
When I was growing up-- this is
one household, one twin--
she always kept the house
perfectly ordered.
I learned from her.
What else could I do?
I had a model in my parent.
She was neat, I'm neat.
Here's the other twin, who
is also very neat.
The reason is quite simple.
I'm reacting to my mother,
who was a complete slob.
OK?
So they're complete
opposite stories.
I'm modeling my parents.
I'm rebelling against
my parents.
But you know that they're
identical twins, and they end
up in the same place.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's another
interpretation.
This is a good question.
The question is, I'm pretending
the explanations
have nothing to do with
anything, and you're saying
maybe this a personality
thing.
Somebody who chooses to model
their parent or just somebody
who chooses to rebel against
their parent.
Maybe that's the personally
dimension, right?
It could be.
It's just neatness.
Twins who aren't neat tend to go
the same way and twins who
are neat tend to go
the same way.
About 50 percent of the effect
is in the genes.
I don't know.
I'm not saying that things
aren't there.
It's a bit of a mystery,
it's a bit of a shock.
So here's a couple
more things.
Biological, non-twin
siblings--
OK, so these are siblings
but they're not twins--
are far more similar
to one another
then adoptive siblings.
OK.
That's OK.
That's the genetics, right?
Because the adopted child
is into the family.
But here's a shocking one.
For personality, children are no
more similar to an adoptive
sibling than are two randomly
selected children.
So in a household, if you have
an adopted child and a
biological child in that
household, sharing the same
environment, they are no more
similar, one to the other,
than two random children
in the world.
OK, where is the effect
of the environment?
Where is the parental effect on
the two children in terms
of personality?
So people have mounted
this argument.
So let me pick another one.
Put up your hand
if you want to.
I'll put up my hand.
How many people grew up in a
household where one or more
parents spoke in a noticeable
accent?
I mean, I did.
Let's just try this here.
How many of you who have your
hand up-- keep your hand up--
did you keep your
parents' accent?
Where's the environment?
In your critical moments of
language development, you were
hearing that accent.
Where is the environment?
And you could say, well, yeah,
but there are other people
speaking other things.
Yeah, but then zero parental
influence on the way in which
you produce your language.
So there's a lot of different
things to think as we move
from language to personality,
but it's turning out to be
surprisingly hard on some
dimensions to show an
influence of parental
environment on child
development, especially
in personality.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, first off, for
the adopted sibling thing.
It seems like that way, not only
would they get similar
parental environment, but they
also probably have similar
school environment--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
It's worse than that.
This is a very good question.
It's not only that they have
adoptive parents, if they have
another kid in the house,
there's another kid in the
house, they probably go to the
same-- if they go to church or
synagogue or anything
like that.
Same school, same state, same
influence of whoever's the NBA
basketball champion.
The whole list.
And it seems to be--
you can't identify
anything in that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Something that is
biological but not in DNA,
that is also 50-50?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So diet would influence that.
Who knows?
AUDIENCE: Stuff like you're born
with, so that it's not
just as an environmental thing,
but it's not, strictly
speaking, in your DNA.
Because that's what
identical twins--
PROFESSOR: Well, let me stop
you there for one moment.
I think at some level of
analysis, all environmental
influences--
education, parenting,
everything--
will have a biological
counterpart in your body and
in your brain, right?
Because the environment has to
affect you by how it changes
your body or brain.
After you're born.
It could be added in.
There's things--
methylation, there's a lot--
yeah, it could be all those
things, but who's
driving that?
So it's not--
my bet is that we'll discover
stuff about this that
we don't grasp yet.
The answer is not going to be
parenting makes no difference,
or environments make no
difference, or schools make no
difference, for personality.
But we just don't know how to
think about that yet is the
best guess, because it's
just hard to believe.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a correlation
between IQ and any
kind of personality?
PROFESSOR: IQ and personality?
There is a moderate--
of conscientiousness
especially,
but that makes sense.
On average--
and we certainly know people
who are very smart and very
sloppy, but on average, the more
conscientious you are,
like if you go to school, you
do your homework, that kinds
of stuff, there is a positive
correlation.
So there's all kinds of--
one question is how much
personality is fixing
your environment.
So how much is the way you are,
from the moment you're
born, driving actually the way
the teacher responds to you in
school, the way the parent
responds to you?
And so that's why your
personality's already driving
your actual environment.
Because we could say, well,
you're in a school, but
really, do you like the
teacher, do you
not like the teacher?
Do you like your parents?
Do you follow them?
Do you oppose them?
Maybe those kinds of things
are happening.
Sometimes people think that your
personality is driving
the way your environment
responds to you.
It might be done by
sibling contrast.
So you may have this
experience that--
parents and other people and
siblings yourself often think
a fair bit how they are similar
or dissimilar from
their own sibling, and
they might overdo it.
Because a parent has two kids,
one kid's like 1% more
outgoing, and they go, that's
the outgoing one.
One kid plays 5% more time on
the piano, and they go, oh,
she's the real musician.
And because he plays two more
baseball games a year, he's
the athlete.
And then it starts to snowball
that way, OK?
Or parent identification.
Could kids who identify with
one parent or the other,
again, by their predispositions,
sort of be
driving the way their parents
interact with them in a way
that's, again, driven
by the personality?
The personality--
from the first moment, for
one reason or another--
is molding the environment
around it and carrying the
environmental effect as well.
So one of the giant fights in
all of psychology is this.
And there's not going to
be an answer, I'll just
tell you the debate.
And it's at the core of this
question of why do we do the
things we do.
So personality adjusted
psychologists will say, it's
these things we've
just discussed.
It's our predispositions to like
things and not like other
things in a general way
are personality.
Social psychologists--
and we'll spend two lectures in
just a few weeks on social
psychology--
say people are all
kind of the same.
It's all about the social
situation we're in.
Probably it's like one of these
nature-nurture things.
Probably something about the
situation is something about
who you are.
But let me tell you how some of
this debate is played out.
So a famous study that went
against the idea of a
personality being constant
across situations and time
came from Walter Mischel.
And they looked at
conscientiousness.
And they said, OK, some kids
score high or low or medium on
conscientiousness.
Now, let's look at 19 specific
behaviors in their life.
Not their report of how they
are, or their parents' report
of how they are, but things they
do that we can measure.
How often do they
make their bed?
How often do they go to class
like they should?
How often do they complete their
homework assignments?
How often do they have
good class notes
when they leave classes?
So things you can check,
yes or no.
And they said gee, what we
notice is somebody tends to be
pretty consistent about whether
they make their bed or
not every morning-- not
perfect, but pretty
consistent.
But that same person may or
may not be so good at
completing homework
assignments.
And that person that's very
consistent on completing
homework assignments may or may
not be so good on having
neat class notes.
So it's not that people aren't
consistent, but it's far more
specific about what they're
consistent about than a big
personality dimension that
covers a range of things that
ought to go together.
So this is situationism.
You behave in a certain way
in a certain situation.
It's not like you have a
personality that moves from
situation to situation and
predicts the same behavior.
And here's another example of
how they follow kids in a
summer camp, and here's
different behaviors from one
child to another child.
So this is a child who, when a
peer approaches, how verbally
aggressive they are.
And so, aggression
is high this way.
These are different
situations.
And you can see for one child
they're aggressive in this
situation when they deal with
an adult, and in this
situation this other child is
aggressive when he or she
deals with a peer.
So if you were to say there's
an aggressive thing about
people-- they're aggressive or
they're not-- well, this
person's aggressive with a
peer, and this person is
aggressive specifically
with an adult.
And so is aggressiveness
a personality thing?
Or situation by situation
by situation?
In the movies you see
all the time--
if you watch The Sopranos or
many movies, it's not uncommon
to have the crime figure be
really kind of nice with his
family, and really brutal with
a competing criminal gang.
Right?
Have you seen that?
They're kind of nice at home,
and then they go shoot people
on two seconds notice
if they're
fighting about something.
So you see that kind
of an idea.
Another thing that people have
looked at that's related to
personality is temperament.
So it's an innate, biologically
based propensity
to engage in a certain
style of behavior.
It's broader than a trait.
I'll describe one that's been
well studied, but people like
it because they think
it's observable.
So with traits, it's hard to
just look at you and say
you're extroverted or you're
conscientious.
I could follow you around
all day and
maybe have an estimate.
But here, temperaments are
broader than traits, and you
can see it in terms of
people's sociability,
emotionality and
activity level.
You can just follow
them and see them
behave in certain ways.
So let's think about the
temperament of shyness.
So the way these studies were
done at Harvard was that some
babies, even at six weeks,
are more reactive
to make sudden noises.
They're more fussy.
About 20% of children
could be that way.
They make a noise or something
and they cry, they get
disturbed, they're unhappy.
And so he called those children
high-reactive or
inhibited babies.
They use those two terms
for the same
idea, versus low reactive.
Ones who were very disturbed by
the environment, and ones
who were, like, no big deal.
And the ones who were inhibited
babies cried more,
they were distressed more, they
showed more activity,
faster heart rates, higher
levels of cortisol.
And they even have-- they could
measure this in some
cases-- faster heart rates
in the womb, even
before they were born.
Their hearts were racing.
So all they'd need is that
one last little thing.
And the idea is that maybe
their sympathetic nervous
system is easily aroused,
seeks less arousing
situations, and it's inhibited
because they're already
internally so aroused,
they want calm.
So there's going to be a
surprise in this story.
But as you go, in terms of
thinking about shyness, and
you can measure these at two
months or four months with
these very simple little things
you do with babies to
see how they respond
to some noise.
And to a decent extent, it
predicts shyness in later
childhood and adulthood.
About a quarter of the children
who look pretty
inhibited aren't shy, but about
75% who look pretty
inhibited end up shy.
So that's a pretty good
prediction from a
two-month-old to
a young adult.
About 75% of these
children who look
pretty shy at two months--
and of course, they're not shy
in a group, they're just
responding to noises--
end up being kind of
shy as adults.
And they studied these until age
21, and again, in several
outcomes, specifically things
like-- let's pick one--
crime, how often they
get in crime.
Children who are well controlled
don't get so much
into crime.
Children who at 21 had poor
control at age three are more
likely to get into trouble.
So as if these temperament
factors in early, early
childhood are already risk
factors for doing better or
worse in the world.
Another one that people enjoy
studying is sensation seeking.
You know, the bungee jumpers,
the people who like to
parachute, people who enjoy
the thrill of activities,
novel, high-stimulation
situations.
Statistically they have more
fun, probably, in some ways.
They're more likely to dive,
they're more likely to drive
fast, they're more likely to
have drug or alcohol use,
they're more likely to send
flame emails, listen to punk
music, and have driving
accidents.
So it's an interesting mix
of enjoyment and trouble.
And there's some evidence they
have lower levels of something
in the blood that may be a
measure of something that lets
dopamine last longer in the
synapse in your brain.
Dopamine is the reward
neurotransmitter.
So you could imagine that if
the reward hangs around
longer, maybe you're more
drawn towards instantly
rewarding things.
Another sort of, I think,
two-dimensional classification
of personality.
Again, one dimension that
he focused on was this
introversion to extroversion
or stable to unstable.
This is neuroticism or
introversion/extroversion in
the big five.
But there's some interesting
turns on this.
Here's the interesting turn.
I mentioned it, but let me
tell you one more time,
because it's counter-intuitive.
It's the opposite of what you
think in terms of what people
have found.
So we think of extroverts as
people who go to parties, are
very talkative, very outgoing,
run around and have a social
time, and introverts as more
likely to be shy, quiet,
withdrawn, right?
That's the definitions
of the words.
But what people have found in
a variety of studies is that
extroverts-- the outgoing
people--
are less easily aroused.
So it's as if they
seek stimulation.
It's as if their internal
arousal is low, and they want
things that are stimulating in
their environment to push up
their internal arousal, right?
Introverts are the
opposite around.
Introverts are aroused already,
and it's as if they
seek environments that are
quiet, so their arousal is not
pushed above some level
of discomfort.
So intuitively you might think
extroverts are more aroused
internally, but the thought is
that extroverts are actually
seeking arousal because they're
a little lower inside.
Introverts are already feeling
pretty aroused, so they don't
need more bungee jumping.
They're already feeling like
they're bungee jumping, OK?
So then they're all seeking
this sort of
optimal level of arousal.
So, for example, extroverts do
better in noisy settings, they
can take the extra stuff,
they don't mind it.
Introverts are more sensitive
to pain, and they salivate
more to lemon juice.
They're already kind of revved
up, is the story, internally.
So here's one--
we couldn't do this early in
the course, and this almost
has practical concept--
you could think about this
for your own test taking.
A three-way interaction.
This is three factors that all
interact with one another in
performance, and it involves
situation and personality.
So here we go.
So the three factors are whether
you're introverted or
extroverted, whether you're
taking a test-- a GRE kind of
a test-- in the morning or the
afternoon, and whether you
drank a cup of coffee before
the test or not.
Three different things
floating around.
And here's what people have
found several times in
experiments when you're
taking a test.
Here's the upshot
of the studies.
If you're introverted and the
test is in the late afternoon
or evening, drink coffee.
If you're outgoing, drink
coffee in the morning.
And I'll tell you the
logic of this.
All right?
So here's the idea.
Many studies have shown-- and
you may know this, if you
think about people you
know or yourself.
On average, introverts are most
aroused in the morning.
They tend to be get up early in
the morning and get their
day going people.
Maybe because they didn't
party deep into
the previous night.
There's cause and effect that's
really hard to pull out
in all of this.
But introverts are more aroused
in the morning and
less in the evening.
On average, they're the kind of
people who are get up early
in the morning, go
do their stuff.
In the evening they want to
mellow down and maybe not go
to sleep so late.
Extroverts are more aroused
in the evening,
and less in the morning.
And this is on average,
and this has been
found a number of times.
So again, you can imagine if
you're taking a test, if
you're under-aroused,
you could use the
coffee to perk you up.
If you're over-aroused, the
coffee is going to make you
jittery and push you over.
So depending on the time of day,
you're going to be in one
state or the other depending
on the kind of
personality you have.
Does that make sense?
These three things come together
like that in the
famous Yerkes-Dodson Law of
performance, which is this.
And this is observed
in many years.
Here's arousal, how
aroused you are.
Super aroused, super nervous,
shaky, so sleepy you're about
to crash out.
Somewhere in the middle
usually goes with best
performance, because
this is too much,
and this is too little.
You know that.
If you're too nervous, you don't
tend to perform well.
If you're too kind of out of
it, you don't perform well.
Somewhere in the middle
is just right.
So here's extroverts,
for example.
In the morning, they're pretty
low on this, they could use
some coffee to move
to optimal.
Here's introverts in the
morning, they're already ready
to go, I'm ready to go,
I'm ready to go.
The last thing they need
is more coffee.
I hope it's not a bubble test
because my hands are shaking.
OK?
So three things.
The kind of personality you
are, the time of day, and
whether your drinking coffee
helps you to move to this
middle position or not.
Does that makes sense?
So that's three different
factors sort of adding up to
optimize performance or not.
OK, lastly I'd like to talk a
little bit about some things
we know about brain correlates
of personality.
And in some areas, these brain
things are more informative at
a broad level.
Because sometimes people will
say, well, personality is all
this check box stuff.
Is it even relevant to
anything biological?
Now, if it's relevant
to behavior,
it's relevant to biology.
Behavior is biology, or
biology is behavior.
We're not going to get one
relative to the other.
But still, until recently,
people couldn't measure this.
So these are pictures of--
not of brain functions, of a
task turning on-- we'll see
pictures of those in a moment.
This is measurement of
brain structure.
Measurement of brain
structure.
And specifically, thickness
of cortex.
So what you're seeing is a
statistic here, which is, the
more extroverted you are, the
thicker your cortex is here.
The more conscientious, the
thicker your cortex here.
The more neurotic, the thicker
your cortex here, and so on.
So we don't understand these
deeply, but we do see
physically measurable
correlates of these
personality dimensions.
So that's physical
brain structure.
Let's talk about some
function things.
This is a slide you saw before
that in the amygdala, the more
emotionally intense something
is, the more the response.
The more neutral it is,
the less the response.
Here's a positive happy
picture, right?
I'm going to show you
a neutral picture.
now the bad picture.
Don't look if you don't
want to see it again.
It's the one you saw before.
Close your eyes for a moment.
Bad picture.
OK.
Here we go.
Now you can all look.
So people are introverted
or extroverted.
Extroverts are sociable,
talkative.
Introverts are, on average,
more reserved or quiet.
Extroverts report more positive
experiences, more
susceptible to positive
mood induction.
Lots of evidence for some
differences among them.
So imagine a study where you
show people positive and
negative slides.
Again, people will say, well,
if I'm on a diet, this is
really negative, or something.
You have people rate them.
But on average these are
negative, and on average these
are positive.
You measure their personality,
and here's what you find in
the amygdala.
The more extroverted they are,
the more their amygdala
responds to positive things.
The more introverted they are,
the more it responds to
negative things.
So here's exactly what we mean
by personality sort of
instantiated in one example.
And it's not the only example.
What do we mean by
personality?
We mean there's a constant
situation--
let's pretend a party
you go to.
A party deep in my memory.
I remember parties I went to,
the music is playing, and
there's sticky beer on the
floor, and there's people you
know and a lot of people
you don't know, right?
So who walks in the door and
thinks this is awesome?
The extrovert, right?
Who walks in the door and thinks
why did my friend drag
me to this?
I could be doing something
good like chess at home.
So now, identical situation,
different-- but that's true of
so many things and preferences
in life.
That's almost what we mean
by personality, right?
Who likes what?
Situations, people,
activities.
So for extroversion, here's the
amygdala going, positive
things, whoopee!
They notice, so to speak, in
their amygdala the positivity
of the environment.
They're drawn to things because
they see positive.
Here is the introverts going,
danger, danger.
OK?
Everybody sees the same set of
slides, but people are drawn
to the positive or the negative
aspects of this.
And you could say, is one
better, the other worse?
Well, no.
Avoiding dangerous things
is a good idea.
Enjoying positive things
One is not better
than the other.
They're just different.
You're tuned to different
rewards in life.
And this is one example
of that.
How about a smiling face?
Who thinks a smiling face is an
invitation to go over and
meet somebody new?
The introvert or
the extrovert?
Help me on this.
Who thinks the smiling
face is pressure?
Do I go over?
Are they smiling at me?
Or I'm going to go over
and then they're
not gonna like me.
They like me now, right?
I should tell you,
I was quite--
only in my teaching mode do
I appear extroverted, OK?
But I definitely was
an introvert in
high school and college.
So if I make fun of
introverts, I'm
making fun of myself.
So here's a response
to fearful faces.
And we talked about that
before, response in the
amygdala regardless
of personality.
But now when we talk about the
response in the amygdala for
happy faces, big response if
you're extroverted, little
response if you're
introverted.
Because a happy face is like
compelling, cool, wonderful
for the extrovert, and not as
enticing for the introvert.
So again, the way we might
imagine, how do individual
differences in personality
play out?
They play out that some things
are beguiling, wonderful, and
other things not so much.
And depending on your
personality, that can vary.
So these are the children who
were studied from the ages of
two and four months who were
shy in temperament,
inhibited, in orange.
And they compared them to
the most uninhibited.
They take the extremes.
But it's a very rare thing when
you have a behavioral
assessment of a child in their
infancy, and then you brain
image them about 20 years later
when they're grown up.
So now you're making this 20
years of your life story, and
again in the amygdala, what
they find is this.
If you look at the people who
are uninhibited, here's a
novel face they see for the
first time in the scanner, or
a face they've seen many times,
and there's not much
difference.
For the people who are
inhibited, you see a much
bigger amygdala response
to the novel face.
Well, this is exactly what you
might intuitively think
shyness would be about.
If you're a shy person and you
know somebody well, I think a
lot of shyness disappears.
But where shyness shows the most
is a face that you don't
know, a new person you haven't
met, and maybe you're not so
comfortable with them yet.
So this is exactly the pattern
you might expect, that it
doesn't matter too much for an
extrovert, a new face, a
familiar face--
made familiar in the experiment,
not somebody you
really know--
it doesn't make much
of a difference.
For the person who is inhibited,
much more response
to the face they see for the
first time only, as opposed to
a face they've grown
familiar with.
A couple more examples
along this line.
Here's another scale.
There's an infinite
number of them.
The Spielberger State and Trait
Anxiety, so, state and
trait, right?
So they ask you-- this is just
a reminder of that--
how do you feel right now?
That would be your state.
Right now.
Do I feel at ease?
Do I feel upset?
And in general, how do you
feel, at ease or upset?
So this is day in day out,
this is right now.
We're going to focus on the
trait, how you say you feel
day in, day out.
And now they're going to show
you faces of people who are
shown in full view, or who are
shown in a subliminal masked
version where a fear or neutral
face is followed by
another face.
This is the critical face.
So you see a face that you see
pretty well, or you see a face
that's presented under
circumstances where you can't
tell what the face was.
OK?
At first they say, what happens
if we show you the
regular face that you
see perfectly well?
Nothing makes much
of a difference.
Here's the amygdala response
to fearful face.
You've seen this now
multiple times.
But kind of interestingly, you
get a smaller response in the
amygdala, and it's driven by
how anxious you report
yourself to be on
a regular basis.
So the interpretation is this.
If you see a fearful face, you
go, well, it's a fearful face,
I know it's a fearful phase,
we're all the same.
If you subliminally present
it, you have an
unknown source of danger.
What we intuitively imagine
anxiety is is feeling danger
or threat in your environment
more than is helpful, more
than is comfortable.
OK?
And you don't even
know exactly why.
It's not entirely rational
when you're
anxious in that way.
And so what happens is, the more
anxious you are, the more
these subliminal faces drive an
amygdala response, and you
don't have control over that,
because you don't know what
happened, because it was
subliminally presented.
Does that make sense?
When it's clear, everybody
knows what to do.
It's just a face and
not that scary.
But when it's an unknown source
of a bit of unease, the
more chronically anxious you
are, the more the brain's
responding.
Or we might say, the bigger
the brain response is the
basis, perhaps, of the
chronic unease.
So we talked also before about
the amygdala being important
for recognizing fearful
expressions.
And then I want to share
two last examples.
How about genetic influences?
So we know genes are a big part
of the story, but how big
a part of the story?
So again, we talked about
single nucleotide
polymorphisms, common
genetic variance.
And here's one that involves
a serotonin
transporter in the amygdala.
There's a short or long allele,
so we'll have two of
these, all of us.
The short allele is
weakly correlated
with anxiety traits.
All this genetic stuff is pretty
weak at the moment, for
reasons that are not
well understood.
I'm only presenting you ones
that have been at least
replicated once.
But practically every genetic
example I'm going to show you,
there's been non-confirmations
as well.
We don't know why this is.
The genes are just so far away
from complex human behaviors
is probably the answer.
But what has been replicated
a number of times is this.
If they show you fearful faces,
and you have the short
allele, the one that's slightly
associated with
anxiety, this is the difference
between people with
the long allele and the shorter
allele, a much more
powerful response to fearful
faces if you
have the shorter allele.
So a single gene can be
correlated with a more potent
response to a sort of
threat stimulus.
And again, that goes with our
sense of anxiety, and what we
might call a less than desirable
response to threat
in the environment.
So here's the last two slides.
But it's the dream we all have
in understanding people, and
actually all animals on the
face of this planet, but
people most of all if you're
curious about people, which
is, what is the interaction
between the genes we're born
with and the life we lead,
and how does that end up
with us being us?
And it's incredibly hard to
study that, because everybody
says in biology and
neuroscience, we know it's a
gene by experience
interaction.
The genes will make you strong
in some circumstances and
vulnerable in others.
But it's very hard
to specify that.
The genes have been
hard to identify.
And we can't put people
into experiments.
We can't say, we'll take two
identical twins and we'll put
one into some horrible household
full of stress and
horribleness, and then one into
a delightful household,
and then see them at 20
and see what happened.
OK?
We're just not allowed
to do that, right?
So we can't experiment on the
environment, and the genes are
poorly understood, very poorly
understood, in relation to
basic human behaviors.
But there's a study from Caspi
that is a glimpse of where we
think the field might
be going.
But I'm going to warn you that
this has not always been
replicated.
It's been replicated sometimes,
but not other times.
So it's an asterisk, but it's
still a finding that's really
quite striking, if it turns
out to be roughly correct.
So again, this is polymorphism
of the same gene that's
associated with anxiety.
And what they did in a very
large sample in New Zealand
was catalog stressful life
events ages 21 to 26, job,
whether you have a job or not,
your salary, decent housing,
terrible housing, good health,
bad health, happy
relationships, no relationships,
terrible
relationships.
People are filling out forms
telling you about the stresses
in their life.
And then they also have
information about childhood
maltreatment.
Some of these children, very
sadly, when they were younger
were treated very poorly, they
were abused in some way or
another, were in very terrible
circumstances, and some not.
So they're going to look at
stressful events in childhood
and adulthood, and sort them
out by the allele that the
individuals have, the gene
version, and what they find
is-- and I'll show you the
graph in a moment--
more depression and suicidality
in response to
stressful events if you have a
short version of the allele.
The short version, we just said,
is the one that seems to
drive a bigger anxiety response
to fearful faces in
the amygdala, OK?
So it seems, first pass, to be
a gene that's associated with
responding in a more anxious way
to environmental stress,
threat, and bad things.
So here's a couple of graphs.
I'll just do a couple
with you.
Here's the probability of major
depression if you've had
no maltreatment as a child, if
you've probably had some, or
you've had documented horrible
maltreatment as a child.
And what you can see if you have
the long version-- this
is this line here--
the long version of this
allele, no difference.
It's as if if you happen to be
born in the biological lottery
that we all participate in at
birth with these version of
these genes-- and maybe many
other genes that are part of
this story, but they just
measured this one.
That it doesn't matter whether
you live in a nice supportive
environment or a brutalizing,
horrible one, your probability
of depression is
about the same.
It's a protective gene for
stresses of life that are
visited upon you.
If you have the opposite,
the short version, look.
The worse the environment, you
double your chances of
depression.
It's as if you're born with a
gene that, if you're given a
terrible environment--
this is exactly the interaction,
right--
then you're very susceptible
to that.
And you see the same rough
pattern in all of them, that
individuals who have this
version of the gene seem to be
relatively impervious to
environmental stressors.
The ones born with this version
of the gene are
terribly-- so if this person's
born with this version of the
gene, but happens to be
in a nice supportive
household, no problem.
Right?
But if they happen to be born
into a household where they
experience, sadly, severe
maltreatment, big problem.
And so this is exactly what we
imagine if we understood in
any depth what people are
about, the genetic
potentiations you're born with,
what's easy for you or
hard for you by genes.
And the world your handed as
an infant, not under your
control, but the environment
you're given, supportive or
threatening, how those two
things play out in a sort of
duet, making you safe or
putting you at risk.
That's exactly what would--
then we would deeply
understand the biology and the
psychology of human life.
So this is the kind of study
that gets a lot of attention,
because if we had it exactly
right, which we don't yet, we
would understand something
really deep about people and
vulnerability in environments.